are you basically saying that once you
get to 999 million dollars that the
government should confiscate all the
rest I'm saying that we should go back
to a very progressive tax policy like
what we had on the Dwight D ISO which
would mean that that
over a billion dollars basically it all
goes to the government you may disagree
with me fine yeah I think people can
make it on 900 you know 99 million
dollars the point here is what are the
mechanisms through which we might
achieve a goal that is quite frankly
quite popular among the American people
when you survey the American people and
you say
should taxation be used
to collect more money from the very rich
in order to fund social programs It's
relatively uncontroversial most
Americans say yes you should